le plan départemental d'insertion
2022-2024 porte les grandes mesures de
l'insertion pour les bénéficiaires du
RSA un axe fort du PDI et le
renforcement de l'accompagnement social
avec pour objectif d'amener les
informations les dispositifs au plus
près des bénéficiaaires une proximité
qui se construit à différents échelons
du territoire au sein des communes des
maisons départementales et des
territoires d'action sociale une
démarche du Halet vert qui s'organise au
sein des iCAS instance de concertation
de la action sociale on a peut-être des
bouts de solutions les les uns aux
autres et quand on met autour de la
table toute une intelligence collective
on voit que on peut en tout cas innover
expérimenter faire un pas peut-être que
ça marchera ça marchera pas on fera on
reculera d'un pas mais c'est peut-être
pour mieux avancer de de de demain en
tout cas l'idée est de de d'aller
chercher pour nos concitoyens tout ce
qui pourrait être fait etess c'est de de
manière la plus intelligente possible et
ça ne se fait que en coopération
avec les différentes strates
d'intervenants au sein de au sein de nos
collectivités territoriales les comités
territoriaux de l'insertion et de
l'emploi rassemblent les partenaires les
employeurs et les structures en charge
de l'accompagnement pour construire des
parcours d'insertion pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA des rencontres de
proximité concentré sur le périmètre
d'action des maisons départementales
c'est un besoin effectivement
aujourd'hui bah de rassembler de fédérer
autour d'actions communes concrètes et
concert qui vont impacter directement
donc le public donc le public pour
lequel on travaille le public accompagné
qui devront trouver en tout cas on
l'espère des solutions adaptées donc à
leur parcours au
port particulièrement nous si on a
installé nos services d'insertion c'est
parce que c'est le plus gros bassin
d'emploi de l'île et un des endroits où
les jeunes connaissent le plus gros tau
de chômage dans certains quartiers donc
c'est effectivement un peu triste que
des personnes qui soient juste à côté de
ses emplois n'est pas les solutions pour
l'AC le renforcement de cette
coordination territoriale de l'action
sociale se concrétise notamment avec les
forums territoriaux de l'insertion et de
l'action sociale sur un même site se
retrouent des plateformes d'information
coanimées par les acteurs locaux c'est
ici la nouvelle dynamique de l'insertion
avec cette démarche du aller vert les
bénéficiaires au plus près des
territoires être présent sur un même
territoire avec un ensemble d'acteurs
pour pouvoir répondre aux besoins de nos
usagers de nos bén
on a loalisé tout un donc un dispositif
qui s'appelle trempl station un
dispositif d'accompagnement renforcé
accès sur du coaching et de
l'accompagnement individualisé et qui
donc est de très courte durée ça fait
donc 80 he et donc au bénéfice donc des
bénéficiaires du RSA qui de qui
autrement n'aurait pas pu se déplacer
jusqu'à sa pi apporter une offre
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
adapté au plus près des bénéficiaires du
RSA c'est tout l'enjeu du PDI est de ces
dispositifs qui engage tous les acteurs
sur tout le
[Musique]
territoire